you wanna know why motherhood is so isolating and being a mom is so lonely
because the second woman hops on a public forum
whether that be TikTok social media or a mommy Facebook group
and talks about how she's struggling or ways in which she is coping
everyone dog piles on that woman
and tells them that they are should never have their children
like I haven't been chronically online this week as much as I usually am
but I've seen the trend going around about the 17 diapers
and correct me if I'm wrong
this is a woman who posted a video where she was caring for her child
and had 17 dirty diapers around her
and y'all
other mothers hopped on the internet to shame this woman for being unhygienic
unclean and like
not taking care of her baby properly
because other mothers love to shame someone
because the second that somebody's doing worse than you
you think that you are doing better
because the worst insult a mother can ever receive
is being told that they are a bad mom
cue the dog pilot cue the sanctum mommies
instead of looking at that situation and empathizing
being like wow someone who's really struggling
would only be the type of person who's doing that
that is not a healthy well functioning
energetic happy
well adjusted person wow
she must be having a really hard time getting through the day
no
and it's because a woman's value is so ingrained in our society
to be tied to her ability to mother and nurture
that every single one of us is fucking terrified of being seen as a bad mom
so instead of lifting each other up
so the best common denominator is all of us coming together to help
and make sure everyone's not struggling
enter the mommy wars the keyboard warriors
and I'm not defending an unhygienic environment for a child
but what I am saying is I've had days where I could get off the floor
so maybe if you've never suffered from postpartum depression
or postpartum anxiety or postpartum OCD or postpartum psychosis
you can sit there on your high horse and say I would never
but calling somebody a shit mom does not make you a better mom
and the only one who can tell you that you're a good mom is your grown ass kids
there is the only opinion that matters
so until you have a grown child who tells you that you were a fantastic parent
and they want a parent just like you shut the fuck up